check yourself before our body pierce
your damn store I think you can pull
that trigger before I blow your
personality at the back of your head
then go right ahead and test the
hypothesis and see what happens all
right I'm gonna give you a straight up
vampire C-section like we was everywhere
hold up
you like Twilight
here is your white one thank you you are
welcome hey Pete little uh little
thirsty tonight
yeah super thirsty Pete this is her
racer all right so this is uh Pete
Harissa just got back from Africa oh
Africa
uh anyways uh where was I oh the AUC oh
right so this conflict is exactly the
reason that the African Union commission
was put in place to address the
organization of African Unity certainly
wasn't going to do anything exactly and
if Costa mini Zuma wants to do anything
about bangui shouldn't have been quiet
about it the worst part about funky is
that no one knows what's going on we
look at right next door the South Sudan
here's the thing everybody just thinks
that it's like it's the damn Lion King
over there you know Lion King
excuse me
it's not the Lion King
exactly
I mean what do people think hey
a baboon is gonna hold a lion cub
over a rock up to the sun while all the
little animals sing
anyway
um something else I wanted to mention is
they have the Manpower because Amazon
has 25 000 troops just sitting there in
Somalia it's not a three animated hyena
situation that doesn't make any sense
the bad guy isn't scar
over there
um yeah yeah that's right it's not like
Scar's the bad guy huh well I mean you
know the truth is no one knows who to
blame because in reality Amazon doesn't
have that much control
like Simba
oh like Simba he had no control over he
was plucked out from his home and went
on a whole journey before he came back
and was just in the middle of a war
really had nothing to do with him you
know Pete I'd be really interested in
hearing your thoughts on the un's
policies in East Africa
Hakuna Matata
unbelievable
yes
there's so much work still to be done
yes that's what I was saying
going how many years so many years
circle of life
exactly that's
brilliant let's dial it back I'm just a
man okay uh I'm gonna
I'm gonna go get some uh some more
droves okay no need to announce it
what are your thoughts on the Middle
East
Aladdin
yeah
Gremlins too
I'm telling you this movie
should write itself first one was a
classic this should be pretty
straightforward basically all we're
doing is maintaining the Integrity of
the original picture we want to do all
the stuff with the water
and the
uh can we help you I'm sorry
let me introduce myself hi y'all my name
is star magic Jackson Jr I'm the
Hollywood sequel doctor so studio just
brings me into oversee things when
they're about to drop a deuce so that's
why I'm here but don't mind me I'm just
gonna be over here y'all do your thing
it's your movie
okay
uh let's brainstorm
Adam uh if it's going to take place in
an office building I was thinking what
if Gizmo gets wet from a water cooler
this time okay hold on a second
what's wrong with y'all
y'all looking like a bunch of side sacks
this is G2 people we write in Gremlins
too it should be a party with pizza and
anchovies pineapple
just come on lift up the spirits look
okay I'm gonna put a little bit of spice
into the mixture here what if we did
this everybody here gets to design their
own Gremlin
um I don't see that the uh the gremlin
design is broken it's called
brainstorming not brain drizzling Sweet
Pea okay shut your mouth for a second
look here's the thing none of this is
finals so you mean like what if there's
like a brainy Grandma a brainy Gremlin
you talking about a gremlin wear glasses
who could talk and sing New York New
York that's brilliant it's in the movie
done
whoa whoa you said that nothing was
Final that was before I heard the words
brainy and Gremlin in the same sentence
together it's done I love it it's in the
movie Next
what about a uh Spider Gremlin you mean
a gremlin with eight legs and a four
racks just catching pretty ladies in a
web in an office building oh my God it's
in the movie I love it next what about a
bat Grandma you mean a gremlin with
leathery Wings just flying around
flip-flopping bust through a wall make a
perfect bat symbol in the wall get
outside get in some wet concrete jump up
on a building and just dry in place like
a gargoyle Gremlin we are cooking with
gas now I love it it's in the movie Next
could there be a female gremlin
snipstick boobies you have me and
little Gremlin but JJ I love it so much
that it's not only in the movie but it's
definitely in the movie there's no
backseats on that one no Penny taxi yes
yes that's in the movie Don that's why
we need a woman in the writer's room
next
I don't know
googly eyed gremlin
you do know because you talking about a
gremlin whose sole purpose in this film
is just that he looks stupidness yes it
can be in the movie and it is in the
movie the next what about you Silver Fox
oh electricity Gremlin you just said
noun and Gremlin like you playing Mad
Libs you just like a child you have the
brain of a child you do not have a high
IQ but you haphazard who came up with a
gremliness is made out of bolts that are
zigzagging all over the room and it's
done completely in animation you a crazy
person and your ideas in the movie done
next can we put the hulkster in it what
[Music]
you talking about putting Hulk Hogan
professional wrestler turned actor
turned cultural icon in the movie where
he break the fourth wall of the movie
he's in by talking to the audience you
sir
our raging psychopath
put this down take that
that's it I don't even care anymore we
got the holster in this so it's
done I don't have any more time so let
me just recap right now it's raining
Gremlin spider Gremlin back Gremlin lady
gremlin googly eye Gremlin electricity
Gremlin Hulk Hogan's gonna be an
adventure imma throw in a grandma myself
vegetable Gremlin just write it up I'm
having so much fun thank you it's all
gonna be in the actual film so I gotta
go put some cowboys and Back To The
Future Three sayonara y'all
[Music]
no okay you guys know that none of that
is gonna be in the actual movie
[Music]
okay you have the most space for
attachments
anyway thank you feel free to hit me up
if you remember that number I noticed
you ain't write that down
damn that girl was fly right shy
did you see that Liam niece's movie with
them wolves though the one with them big
ass wolves and Liam neesons is
oh Liam Neeson straight jacked up them
wolves
and don't even get me started on that
one when they took his daughter
straight talking starring Liam neesons
man leave me this is on the phone like I
have a certain shot of skills
don't even try and be rushing around
near me
and the second one the Russians come
after him and he them all up
anyway took him two starring the
incomparable Liam neesons
oh no what about Liam Neeses in some
dark man no what about darkness when
Liam needs his face
homie was straight face changing now
that's just Liam neesis acting right
there straight up I kid you not Academy
Award caliber classic nieces seriously I
mean like nieces already he do have a
statue yeah no he ain't got a statue he
ain't got a statue he ain't got a statue
nope nope nope
[Music]
the Oscar goes to Liam Neeson's dark man
face was changing how hard is that ain't
hard it's not hard at all damn
battleship
[Applause]
Liam Neeson straight killed a robot boat
Liam neesis is my shiznit oh
but you know who I like as much as
nieces through as much as Nissans who
Bruce Willie
ah Bruce Willie is my oh what if they
made a movie with Liam Neeson's and
Bruce Willie
nieces and Willie
ugly in the slaughter man harder
what what what what what sex yourself
before our body pierced your damn skull
I think you can pull that trigger before
I blow your personality out the back of
your head they'll go right ahead and
test the hypothesis and see what happens
all right I'm gonna give you a straight
up vampire C-section like we was Edward
and Bella
hold up you like Twilight yeah I like
Twilight
you like Twilight Twilight's my jam
you were Edwin go and take him
answer that together three two one
Edwards
are you with me are you
with me you're either playing some
up game or you were straight up
inside my head yo and when you said you
was gonna blow my personality out the
back of my head I'm like
that sounds like something I would say
and now there's Twilight wavelength so I
guess we friends then are we best
friends now we the best of friends BFFs
we are BFFs MF
[Applause]
[Music]
when we do
trumpets start to sound when
crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
too much
team
yeah looks like another Gang Related
killing
surprise the mother prize
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't know